these days Mark Ruffalo seems to be
riding high on his blockbuster success
but in reality the actor has endured
overwhelming challenges to get where he
is today from life-threatening health
issues to the loss of those closest to
him here's a look at Mark Ruffalo's
tragic real-life story Ruffalo grew up
in Wisconsin alongside his brother and
two sisters
but according to Men's Journal when his
father Frank's painting business went
under the family moved to Virginia Beach
then when a second business tanked the
Ruffalo's headed west your
great-great-grandfather was once the
richest man in Boston who was so poor in
San Diego Frank was only able to find
temporary work and the family spiraled
into bankruptcy mark who had just
graduated high school has recalled in
several interviews that the family was
living in a neighborhood where drugs
like meth were commonly sold as Ruffalo
recalls it grade school was difficult
he told parade I was miserable this
sounds sappy but I was always aware of
the frailty of human beings the sorrow
and the nature of things I didn't know
how to live in the world how to cope I
felt like I didn't belong later in life
Ruffalo discovered he had been suffering
from undiagnosed ADHD and dyslexia in
2017 he teamed up with the child mind
Institute on their my younger self
initiative revealing a bit of his own
journey with mental health Ravello even
moved his young family from upstate New
York back to New York City so his
children could attend to school with the
program for dyslexic students should
they need it while Ruffalo was living in
LA he had a best friend named Michael
the actor described their common bond
telling parade he was the only one I
knew as sad as me who I could talk to
but in 1994 Michael succumbed to his own
depression and took his own life
Ruffalo remembered when he died it
rocked me out of a dark depression the
moment he left I realized that death
wasn't an escape to Ruffalo acting
became a way of moving forward past the
pain of his younger years Ruffalo has
dealt with depression for his entire
life and according to New York magazine
after high school as his friends were
going to college Ruffalo said he instead
spent most of his time smoking surfing
and wandering around aimlessly he worked
as a busboy and said he was just
ready to jump off a bridge Ruffalo now
has a name for it telling the observer
its dysthymia it's a long-running
low-grade depression all the time I've
been struggling with that my whole life
the actor credits meditation with
changing his outlook revealing to
Rolling Stone it's pretty much a daily
practice that quiets your brain and
oddly enough actually slows down time so
you're not so much trapped in your
immediate reactions to things my work
started to change my luck started to
change the way the world looked to me
changed after having a dream that he had
a brain tumor a cat scan confirmed
Ruffalo had developed an acoustic
neuroma a benign tumor in his brain she
said you have a you have a mass behind
your left ear the size of a bit of a
golf ball it was a trying time yeah it
was very scary I found out and then our
baby was born two weeks later several
weeks after the birth of his son Keene
Ruffalo underwent surgery to remove the
tumor but even though the operation was
a success
he lost hearing in his left ear and that
side of his face was completely
paralyzed the crisis couldn't have come
at a worse time for Ruffalo's career
either due to the complications he
retreated to his home where he stayed in
self-imposed exile unable to work it
lasted a long time it lasted to the
point where they were saying you're
probably not gonna get your interface
back after six months of paralysis
Ruffalo beat the odds and was able to
make very slight movements signaling the
beginning of his recovery according to
the LA Times Marc's brother Scott
Ruffalo died a week after being shot in
the head in his own home in 2008
initially it appeared that Scott might
have died playing Russian roulette
but eventually the case was ruled a
homicide police questioned shahe
Michelle Adam and her boyfriend Brian
Scofield after they willingly came
forward shahe claims she visited Scott
to pick up some keys said Scott then
mentioned something about Russian
roulette and shahe says she heard a
gunshot shortly after she was booked but
then released and in 2012 she suddenly
died leaving the case without a critical
witness Scott's murder remains unsolved
you know it's it'll be the great mystery
of my life following his brother's death
Ruffalo took a break from Hollywood he
told The Telegraph my brother passing
away reminded me that life is short
and you'd better do what you want while
you have a chance Ruffalo fired his
agent and publicist left his apartment
in LA and moved to a secluded home in
upstate New York with his wife and three
children
still Ruffalo couldn't completely leave
the business and went on to make his
directorial debut with 2010's sympathy
for delicious Ruffalo remained
semi-retired from acting until he read
the script for The Kids Are Alright as
he told The Telegraph he took on the
project in memory of his brother this
incredibly beautiful sexy vibrant the
fun-loving guy it was a way for me to no
say thank you to the actor has since
gone on to envy Abul success despite the
many devastating challenges he's faced
in his life he looked back on his
struggle telling life and style I was
tending bar at Chateau Marmont and I'd
see Johnny Depp and Nick Cage hanging
around hugely successful while I was
barely making a living
I must have auditioned 800 times without
landing apart thanks to the support of
his wife and three children and a whole
lot of honest work on his well being the
guy now widely known as Hulk from The
Avengers is living his best life just be
patient and and accept the journey that
you've been that you've been asked to
take if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline at
1-800 to 73 talk that's one eight
hundred two seven three eight two five
five
[Music]